[Music]
the following events
occurred on a small island of isolated
position in a large canadian lake
to whose cool waters the inhabitants of
montreal and toronto
flee for rest and recreation in the hot
months
it is only to be regretted that events
of such peculiar interest to the genuine
student of the psychical
should be entirely uncorroborated such
unfortunately however
is the case our own party of nearly 20
had returned to montreal that very day
and i was left in solitary possession
for a week or two longer
in order to accomplish some important
reading for the law which i had
foolishly neglected during the summer
it was late in september and the big
trout and muscalunge were stirring
themselves in the depths of the lake
and beginning slowly to move up to the
surface waters as the north winds and
early frosts lowered their temperature
already the maples were crimson and gold
and the wild laughter of the loons
echoed in sheltered bays
that never knew their strange cry in the
summer
with a whole island to oneself a
two-story cottage
a canoe and only the chipmunks and the
farmer's weekly visit with eggs and
bread to disturb one
the opportunities for hard reading might
be very great
it all depends the rest of the party had
gone off with many warnings to beware of
indians
and not to stay late enough to be the
victim of a frost that thinks nothing of
40 below zero
after they had gone the loneliness of
the situation made itself
unpleasantly felt there were no other
islands within six or seven miles
and though the mainland forest lay a
couple of miles behind me
they stretched for a very great distance
unbroken by any signs of human
habitation
but though the island was completely
deserted and silent the rocks and trees
that had echoed human laughter and
voices almost every hour of the day for
two months
could not fail to retain some memories
of it all and i was not surprised to
fancy i heard a shout or a cry
as i passed from rock to rock and more
than once to imagine that i heard my own
name called aloud
in the cottage there were six tiny
little bedrooms divided from one another
by plain unvarnished partitions of pine
a wooden bedstead a mattress and a chair
stood in each room
but i only found two mirrors and one of
these was broken
the boards creaked a good deal as i
moved about and the signs of occupation
were so recent that i could hardly
believe i was alone
i half expected to find someone left
behind still trying to crowd into a box
more than it would hold
the door of one room was stiff and
refused for a moment to open
and it required very little persuasion
to imagine someone was holding the
handle on the inside
and that when it opened i should meet a
pair of human eyes
a thorough search of the floor led me to
select as my own sleeping quarters a
little room with a diminutive balcony
over the veranda roof
the room was very small but the bed was
large and had the best mattress of them
all
it was situated directly over the
sitting room where i should live and do
my reading
and the miniature window looked out to
the rising sun
with the exception of a narrow path
which led from the front door and
veranda
through the trees to the boat landing
the island was densely covered with
maples hemlocks and cedars
the trees gathered in round the cottage
so closely that the slightest wind made
the branches scrape the roof
and tap the wooden walls a few moments
after sunset the darkness became
impenetrable
and 10 yards beyond the glare of the
lamps that shone through the sitting
room windows
of which there were four you could not
see an inch before your nose
nor move a step without running up
against a tree
the rest of that day i spent moving my
belongings from my tent to the sitting
room
taking stock of the contents of the
larter and chopping enough wood for the
stove to last me for a week
after that just before sunset i went
round the island a couple of times in my
canoe
for precautions sake i had never dreamed
of doing this before
but when a man is alone he does things
that never occur to him when he is one
of a large party
how lonely the island seemed when i
landed again
the sun was down and twilight is unknown
in these northern regions
the darkness comes up at once the canoe
safely pulled up
and turned over on her face i groped my
way up the little narrow pathway to the
veranda
the six lamps were soon burning merrily
in the front room
but in the kitchen where i dined the
shadows were so gloomy and the lamplight
was so inadequate
that the stars could be seen peeping
through the cracks between the rafters
i turned in early that night though it
was calm and there was no wind
the creaking of my bedstead and the
musical gurgle of the water over the
rocks below
were not the only sounds that reached my
ears as i lay awake the appalling
emptiness of the house grew upon me
the corridors and vacant rooms seemed to
echo innumerable footsteps
shufflings the rustle of skirts and a
constant undertone of whispering
when sleep at length overtook me the
breathings and noises however
passed gently to mingle with the voices
of my dreams
a week passed by and the reading
progressed favorably
on the tenth day of my solitude a
strange thing happened
i awoke after a good night's sleep to
find myself possessed with a marked
repugnance for my room
the air seemed to stifle me the more i
tried to define the cause of this
dislike
the more unreasonable it appeared there
was something about the room that made
me afraid
absurd as it seems this feeling clung to
me obstinately while dressing
and more than once i caught myself
shivering and conscious of an
inclination to get out of the room as
quickly as possible
the more i tried to laugh it away the
more real it became
and when at last i was dressed and went
out into the passage and downstairs into
the kitchen
it was with feelings of relief such as i
might imagine would accompany one's
escape from the presence of a dangerous
contagious disease
while cooking my breakfast i carefully
recalled every night spent in the room
in the hope that i might in some way
connect the dislike i now felt
with some disagreeable incident that had
occurred in it
but the only thing i could recall was
one stormy night when i suddenly awoke
and heard the boards creaking so loudly
in the corridor
that i was convinced there were people
in the house so certain was i of this
that i had descended the stairs gun in
hand only to find the doors and windows
securely fastened
and the mice and black beetles in sole
possession of the floor
this was certainly not sufficient to
account for the strength of my feelings
the morning hours i spent in steady
reading and when i broke off in the
middle of the day
for lunch and a swim i was very much
surprised if not a little alarmed
to find that my dislike for the room had
if anything grown stronger
going upstairs to get a book i
experienced the most market aversion to
entering the room
and while within i was conscious all the
time of an uncomfortable feeling
that was half uneasiness and half
apprehension
the result of it was that instead of
reading i spent the afternoon on the
water
paddling and fishing and when i got home
about sundown
brought with me half a dozen delicious
black bass for the supper table and the
larder
as sleep was an important matter to me
at this time i had decided that if my
aversion to the room was so strongly
marked on my return
as it had been before i would move my
bed down into the sitting room and sleep
there
this was i argued in no sense a
concession to an absurd and fanciful
fear
but simply a precaution to ensure a good
night's sleep
a bad night involved the loss of the
next day's reading a loss i was not
prepared to incur
i accordingly moved my bed downstairs
into a corner of the sitting room facing
the door
and was moreover uncommonly glad when
the operation was completed
and the door of the bedroom closed
finally upon the shadows
the silence and the strange fear that
shared the room with them
the croaking stroke of the kitchen clock
sounded the hour of eight
as i finished washing up my few dishes
and closing the kitchen door behind me
passed into the front room all the lamps
were lit
and their reflectors which i had
polished up during the day
threw a blaze of light into the room
outside the night was still and warm
not a breath of air was stirring the
waves were silent
the trees motionless and heavy clouds
hung like an oppressive curtain over the
heavens
the darkness seemed to have rolled up
with unusual swiftness
and not the faintest glow of color
remain to show where the sun had set
there was present in the atmosphere that
ominous and overwhelming silence which
so often precedes the most violent
storms
i sat down to my books with my brain
unusually clear
and in my heart the pleasant
satisfaction of knowing that five black
bass were lying in the ice house
and that tomorrow morning the old farmer
would arrive with fresh bread and eggs
i was soon absorbed in my books
as the night wore on the silence
deepened even the chipmunks were still
and the boards of the floors and walls
ceased creaking
i read on steadily till from the gloomy
shadows of the kitchen
came the hoarse sound of the clock
striking nine
how loud the stroke sounded they were
like blows of a big hammer
i closed one book and opened another
feeling that i was just warming up to my
work
this however did not last long i
presently found that i was reading the
same paragraphs over twice
simple paragraphs that did not require
such effort
then i noticed that my mind began to
wander to other things
and the effort to recall my thoughts
became harder with each digression
concentration was growing momentarily
more difficult
presently i discovered that i had turned
over two pages instead of one
and had not noticed my mistake until i
was well down the page
this was becoming serious what was the
disturbing influence
it could not be physical fatigue on the
contrary my mind was unusually alert and
in a more receptive condition than usual
i made a new and determined effort to
read and for a short time succeeded in
giving my whole attention to my subject
but in a very few moments again i found
myself leaning back in my chair
staring vacantly into space something
was evidently at work in my subconscious
there was something i had neglected to
do perhaps the kitchen door and windows
were not fastened
i accordingly went to see and found that
they were
the fire perhaps needed attention i went
in to see
and found that it was all right i looked
at the lamps
went upstairs into every bedroom and
turn and then went round the house
and even into the ice house nothing was
wrong everything was in its place
yet something was wrong the conviction
grew stronger and stronger within me
when i at length settled down to my
books again and tried to read
i became aware for the first time that
the room seemed to be growing cold
yet the day had been oppressively warm
and evening had brought no relief
the six big lamps moreover gave out heat
enough to warm the room pleasantly
but a chilliness that perhaps crept up
from the lake
made itself felt in the room and caused
me to get up to close the glass door
opening onto the veranda for a brief
moment i stood looking out at the shaft
of light that fell from the windows
and shown some little distance down the
pathway and out for a few feet into the
lake
as i looked i saw a canoe glide into the
pathway of light
and immediately crossing it passed out
of sight again into the darkness
it was perhaps a hundred feet from the
shore and it moved swiftly
i was surprised that a canoe should pass
the island at that time of night
for all the summer visitors from the
other side of the lake had gone home
weeks before
and the island was a long way out of any
line of water traffic
my reading from this moment did not make
very good progress
for somehow the picture of that canoe
gliding so dimly and swiftly across the
narrow track of light on the black
waters
silhouetted itself against the
background of my mind with singular
vividness
it kept coming between my eyes and the
printed page
the more i thought about it the more
surprised i became
it was of larger build than any i had
seen during the past summer months
and was more like the old indian war
canoes with the high curving boughs and
stern and wide beam
the more i tried to read the less
success attended my efforts
and finally i closed my books and went
out on the veranda to walk up and down a
bit
and shake the chilliness out of my bones
the night was perfectly still
and as dark as imaginable i stumbled
down the path to the little landing
wharf
where the water made the very faintest
of gurgling under the timbers
the sound of a big tree falling in the
mainland forest far across the lake
stirred echoes in the heavy air
like the first guns of a distant night
attack no other sound disturbed the
stillness that reigned supreme
as i stood upon the wharf and the broad
splash of light that followed me from
the sitting room windows i saw another
canoe
cross the pathway of uncertain light
upon the water and disappear at once
into the impenetrable gloom that lay
beyond
this time i saw more distinctly than
before
it was like the former canoe a big birch
bark with high crested boughs and stern
and broad beam
it was paddled by two indians of whom
the one in the stern
the steerer appeared to be a very large
man
i could see this very plainly and though
the second canoe was much nearer the
island than the first
i judged that they were both on their
way home to the government reservation
which was situated some 15 miles away
upon the mainland
i was wondering in my mind what could
possibly bring any indians down to this
part of the lake at such an hour of the
night
when a third canoe a precisely similar
build and also
occupied by two indians passed silently
around the end of the wharf
this time the canoe was very much nearer
shore and it suddenly flashed into my
mind that the three canoes were in
reality
one and the same and that only one canoe
was circling the island
this was by no means a pleasant
reflection because if it were the
correct solution of the unusual
appearance of the three canoes in this
lonely part of the lake it's so late an
hour
the purpose of the two men could only
reasonably be considered
to be in some way connected with myself
i had never known of the indians
attempting any violence upon the
settlers who
shared the wild inhospitable country
with them at the same time it was not
beyond the region of possibility to
suppose
but then i did not even care to think of
such hideous possibilities
and my imagination immediately sought
relief in all manner of other solutions
to the problem
which indeed came readily enough to my
mind but did not succeed in recommending
themselves to my reason
meanwhile by a sort of instinct i
stepped back out of the bright light in
which i had hitherto been standing
and waited in the deep shadow of a rock
to see if the canoe would again make its
appearance
here i could see without being seen and
the precaution seemed a wise one
after less than five minutes the canoe
as i had anticipated
made its fourth appearance this time it
was not 20 yards from the wharf
and i saw that the indians meant to land
i recognized the two men as those who
had passed before
and the steerer was certainly an immense
fellow it was unquestionably the same
canoe there could no longer be any doubt
that for some purpose of their own
the men had been going round and round
the island for some time
waiting for an opportunity to land i
strained my eyes to follow them in the
darkness
but the knight had completely swallowed
them up and not even the faintest swish
of the paddles reached my ears
as the indians plied their long and
powerful strokes
the canoe would be round again in a few
moments and this time it was possible
that the men might land it was well to
be prepared
i knew nothing of their intentions and
two to one when the two were big indians
late at night on a lonely island was not
exactly my idea of pleasant intercourse
in a corner of the sitting room leaning
up against the back wall
stood my marlin rifle with 10 cartridges
in the magazine
and one lying snugly in the greased
breech there was just time to get up to
the house and take up a position of
defense in that corner
without an instant hesitation i ran up
to the veranda
carefully picking my way among the trees
so as to avoid being seen in the light
entering the room i shut the door
leading to the veranda and as quickly as
possible turned out every one of the six
lamps to be in a room so brilliantly
lighted
where my every movement could be
observed from outside while i could see
nothing but impenetrable darkness at
every window
was by all laws of warfare and
unnecessary concession to the enemy
and this enemy if enemy it was to be was
far too wily and dangerous to be granted
any such advantages
i stood in the corner of the room with
my back against the wall and my hand on
the cold rifle barrel
the table covered with my books lay
between me and the door
but for the first few minutes after the
lights were out the darkness was so
intense that nothing could be discerned
at all
then very gradually the outline of the
room became visible
and the framework of the windows began
to shape itself dimly before my eyes
after a few minutes the door its upper
half of glass
and the two windows that looked out upon
the front veranda became specially
distinct
and i was glad that this was so because
if the indians came up to the house i
should be able to see their approach
and gather something of their plans nor
was i mistaken
for their presently came to my ears the
peculiar hollow sound of a canoe landing
and being carefully dragged up over the
rocks
the paddles i distinctly heard being
placed underneath and the silence that
ensued there upon i rightly interpreted
to mean that the indians were stealthily
approaching the house
while it would be absurd to claim that i
was not alarmed even frightened at the
gravity of the situation
and its possible outcome i speak the
whole truth when i say that i was not
overwhelmingly afraid for myself
i was conscious that even at this stage
of the night i was passing into a
psychical condition
in which my sensation seemed no longer
normal
physical fear at no time entered into
the nature of my feelings
and though i kept my hand upon my rifle
the greater part of the night
i was all the time conscious that its
assistance could be of little avail
against the terrors that i had to face
more than once i seemed to feel most
curiously that i was in no real sense a
part of the proceedings
nor actually involved in them but that i
was playing the part of a spectator
a spectator moreover on a psychic rather
than on a material plane
many of my sensations that night were
too vague for definite description and
analysis
but the main feeling that will stay with
me to the end of my days
is the awful horror of it all and the
miserable sensation that if the strain
had lasted a little longer than was
actually the case
my mind must inevitably have given way
meanwhile i stood still in my corner and
waited patiently for what was to come
the house was as still as the grave but
the inarticulate voices of the night
sang in my ears and i seemed to hear the
blood running in my veins
and dancing in my pulses if the indians
came to the back of the house
they would find the kitchen door and
window securely fastened
they could not get in there without
making considerable noise which i was
bound to hear
the only mode of getting in was by means
of the door that faced me
and i kept my eyes glued on that door
without taking them off for the smallest
fraction of a second
my sight adapted itself every minute
better to the darkness
i saw the table that nearly filled the
room and left only a narrow passage on
each side
i could also make out the straight backs
of the wooden chairs pressed up against
it
and could even distinguish my papers and
ink stand lying on the white oil cloth
covering i thought of the gay faces that
had gathered around that table during
the summer
and i longed for the sunlight as i had
never longed for it before
less than three feet to my left the
passageway led to the kitchen
and the stairs leading to the bedrooms
above commenced in this passageway
but almost in the sitting room itself
through the windows i could see the dim
motionless outlines of the trees
not a leaf stirred not a branch moved
a few moments of this awful silence and
then i was aware of a soft tread on the
boards of the veranda
so stealthy that it seemed an impression
directly on my brain
rather than upon the nerves of hearing
immediately afterwards a black figure
darkened the glass door
and i perceived that a face was pressed
against the upper panes
a shiver ran down my back and my hair
was conscious of a tendency to rise and
stand at right angles to my head
it was the figure of an indian
broad-shouldered and immense
indeed the largest figure of a man i
have ever seen outside of a circus hall
by some power of light that seemed to
generate itself in the brain
i saw the strong dark face with the
aqualine nose
and high cheekbones flattened against
the glass the direction of the gaze i
could not determine
but faint gleams of light as the big
eyes rolled round and showed their
whites
told me plainly that no corner of the
room escaped their searching
for what seemed fully five minutes the
dark figure stood
there with the huge shoulders bent
forward so as to bring the head down to
the level of the glass
while behind him though not nearly so
large the shadowy form of the other
indians swayed to and fro like a bent
tree
while i waited in an agony of suspense
and agitation for their next movement
little currents of icy sensation ran up
and down my spine
and my heart seemed alternately to stop
beating and then start off again with
terrifying rapidity
they must have heard its thumping and
the singing of the blood in my head
moreover i was conscious as i felt a
cold stream of perspiration trickle down
my face
of a desire to scream to shout to bang
the walls like a child
to make a noise or do anything that
would relieve the suspense and bring
things to a speedy climax
it was probably this inclination that
led me to another discovery
for when i tried to bring my rifle from
behind my back to raise it and have it
pointed at the door ready to fire
i found that i was powerless to move the
muscles
paralyzed by this strange fear refused
to obey the will
here indeed was a terrifying
complication
there was a faint sound of rattling at
the brass knob and the door was pushed
open a couple of inches
a pause of a few seconds and it was
pushed open still further
without a sound of footsteps that was
appreciable to my ears
the two figures glided into the room and
the man behind gently closed the door
after him
they were alone with me between the four
walls
could they see me standing there so
still and straight in my corner
had they perhaps already seen me my
blood surged and sang like the roll of
drums in an orchestra
and though i did my best to suppress my
breathing it sounded like the rushing of
wind through a pneumatic tube
my suspense as to the next move was soon
at an end
only however to give place to a new and
keener alarm
the men had hitherto exchanged no words
and no signs
but there were general indications of a
movement across the room
and whichever way they went they would
have to pass around the table
if they came my way they would have to
pass within six inches of my person
while i was considering this very
disagreeable possibility
i perceived that the smaller indian
smaller by comparison
suddenly raised his arm and pointed to
the ceiling the other fellow raised his
head and followed the direction of his
companion's arm
i began to understand at last they were
going upstairs
and the room directly overhead to which
they pointed had been
until this night my bedroom it was the
room in which i had experienced that
very morning
so strange a sensation of fear and but
for which i should then have been lying
asleep in the narrow bed against the
window
the indians then began to move silently
around the room
they were going upstairs and they were
coming around my side of the table
so stealthy were their movements that
but for the abnormally sensitive state
of the nerves i should never have heard
them
as it was their cat-like tread was
distinctly audible
like two monstrous black cats they came
round the table toward me
and for the first time i perceived that
the smaller of the two dragged something
along the floor behind him
as it trailed along over the floor with
a soft sweeping sound
i somehow got the impression that it was
a large dead thing with outstretched
wings
or a large spreading cedar branch
whatever it was i was unable to see it
even an outline
and i was too terrified even had i
possessed the power over my muscles
to move my neck forward in the effort to
determine its nature
nearer and nearer they came the leader
rested a giant
hand upon the table as he moved my lips
were glued together
and the air seemed to burn in my
nostrils i tried to close my eyes
so that i might not see as they passed
me but my eyelids had stiffened and
refused to obey would they never get by
me
sensation seemed also to have left my
legs and it was as if i were standing on
mere supports of wood or stone
worse still i was conscious that i was
losing the power of balance
the power to stand upright or even to
lean backwards against the wall
some force was drawing me forward and a
dizzy terror sees me that i should lose
my balance
and topple forward against the indians
just as they were in the act of passing
me
even moments drawn out into hours must
come to an end sometime
and almost before i knew it the figures
had passed me and had their feet upon
the lower step of the stairs leading to
the upper bedrooms
there could not have been six inches
between us and yet i was conscious only
of a current of cold air that followed
them
they had not touched me and i was
convinced that they had not seen me
even the trailing thing on the floor
behind them had not touched my feet as i
had dreaded it would
and on such an occasion as this i was
grateful even for the smallest
mercies the absence of the indians from
my immediate neighborhood brought little
sense of relief
i stood shivering and shuddering in my
corner and beyond being able to breathe
more freely
i felt no wit less uncomfortable also i
was aware that a certain light
which without a parent's source or rays
had enabled me to follow their every
gesture and movement
had gone out of the room with their
departure
an unnatural darkness now filled the
room and pervaded its every corner so
that i could barely make out the
positions of the windows and the glass
doors
as i said before my condition was
evidently an abnormal one
the capacity for feeling surprise seemed
as in dreams to be wholly absent
my senses recorded with unusual accuracy
every smallest occurrence
but i was able to draw only the simplest
deductions
the indians soon reached the top of the
stairs and there they halted for a
moment
i had not the faintest clue as to their
next movement they appeared to hesitate
they were listening attentively then i
heard one of them
who by the weight of his soft tread must
have been the giant cross the narrow
corridor
and enter the room directly overhead my
own little bedroom
but for the insistence of that
unaccountable dread i had experienced
there in the morning
i should at that very moment have been
lying in the bed with the big indian in
the room standing beside me
for the space of a hundred seconds there
was silence such as might have existed
before the birth of sound
it was followed by a long quivering
shriek of terror
which rang out into the night and ended
in a short gulp
before it had run its full course at the
same moment the other indian left his
place at the head of the stairs
and joined his companion in the bedroom
i heard the thing trailing behind him
along the floor
a thud followed as of something heavy
falling and then all became as still and
silent as before
it was at this point that the atmosphere
surcharged all day with the electricity
of a fierce storm
found relief in a dancing flash of
brilliant lightning simultaneously with
a crash of loudest thunder
for five seconds every article in the
room was visible to me with amazing
distinctness
and through the windows i saw the tree
trunks standing in solemn rows
the thunder peeled and echoed across the
lake and among the distant islands
and the floodgates of heaven then opened
and let out their rain and streaming
torrents
the drops fell with a swift rushing
sound upon the still waters of the lake
which leaped up to meet them and
pattered with the rattle of shot
on the leaves of the maples and the roof
of the cottage
a moment later and another flash even
more brilliant and of longer duration
than the first
lit up the sky from zenith to horizon
and bathed the room momentarily in
dazzling whiteness
i could see the rain glistening on the
leaves and branches outside
the wind rose suddenly and in less than
a minute the storm that had been
gathering all day
burst forth in its full fury above all
the noisy voices of the elements
the slightest sounds in the room
overhead made themselves heard
and in the few seconds of deep silence
that followed the shriek of terror and
pain
i was aware that the movements had
commenced again
the men were leaving the room and
approaching the top of the stairs
a short pause and they began to descend
behind them tumbling from step to step
i could hear that trailing thing being
dragged along
it had become ponderous i awaited their
approach with a degree of calmness
almost of apathy which was only
explicable on the ground that after a
certain
point nature applies her own anesthetic
and a merciful condition of numbness
supervenes
on they came step by step nearer and
nearer
with the shuffling sound of the burden
behind growing louder as they approached
they were already halfway down the
stairs when i was galvanized afresh
into a condition of terror by the
consideration of a new and horrible
possibility
it was the reflection that if another
vivid flash of lightning were to come
when the shadowy procession was in the
room perhaps when it was actually
passing in front of me
i should see everything in detail and
worse be seen myself
i could only hold my breath and wait
wait while the minutes lengthened into
hours
and the procession made its slow
progress around the room
the indians had reached the foot of the
staircase the form of a huge leader
loomed in the doorway of the passage and
the burden with an ominous thud had
dropped from the last step to the floor
there was a moment's pause while i saw
the indian turn and stoop to assist his
companion
then the procession moved forward again
entered the room
close on my left and began to move
slowly around my side of the table
the leader was already beyond me and his
companion dragging on the floor behind
him the burden
whose confused outline i could dimly
make out was exactly in front of me
when the cavalcade came to a dead halt
at the same moment with the strange
suddenness of thunderstorms
the splash of the rain ceased altogether
and the wind died away
into utter silence for the space of five
seconds my heart seemed to stop beating
and then the worst came a double flash
of lightning lit up the room and its
contents with merciless vividness
the huge indian leader stood a few feet
past me on my right
one leg was stretched forward in the act
of taking a step
his immense shoulders were turned toward
his companion and in all their
magnificent fierceness i saw the outline
of his features
his gaze was directed upon the burden
his companion was dragging along the
floor
but his profile with the big aquiline
nose high cheekbones
straight black hair and bold chin burnt
itself in that brief instant into my
brain
never again to fade dwarfish
compared with this gigantic figure
appeared the proportions of the other
indian
who within 12 inches of my face was
stooping over the thing he was dragging
in a position that lent to his person
the additional horror of deformity
and the burden lying upon a sweeping
cedar branch which he held and dragged
by a long stem
was the body of a white man the scalp
had been neatly lifted
and blood lay in a broad smear upon the
cheeks and forehead
then for the first time that night the
terror that had paralyzed my muscles and
my will
lifted its unholy spell from my soul
with a loud cry i stretched out my arms
to seize the big indian by the throat
and grasping only air tumbled forward
unconscious upon the ground
i had recognized the body and the face
was my own
it was bright daylight when a man's
voice recalled me to consciousness
i was lying where i had fallen and the
farmer was standing in the room with the
loaves of bread in his hands
the horror of the night was still in my
heart and as the bluff settler
helped me to my feet and picked up the
rifle which had fallen with me
with many questions and expressions of
condolence i imagine my brief replies
were neither self-explanatory nor even
intelligible
that day after a thorough and fruitless
search of the house
i left the island and went over to spend
my last 10 days with the farmer
and when the time came for me to leave
the necessary reading had been
accomplished
and my nerves had completely recovered
their balance
on the day of my departure the farmer
started early in his big boat with my
belongings to roe to the point
12 miles distant where a little steamer
ran twice a week for the accommodation
of hunters
late in the afternoon i went off in
another direction in my canoe
wishing to see the island once again
where i had been the victim of so
strange an experience
in due course i arrived there and made a
tour of the island
i also made a search of the little house
and it was not without a curious
sensation in my
heart that i entered the little upstairs
bedroom
there seemed nothing unusual just after
i re-embarked
i saw a canoe gliding ahead of me around
the curve of the island
a canoe was an unusual sight at this
time of the year
and this one seemed to have sprung from
nowhere
altering my course a little i watched it
disappear around the next projecting
point of rock
it had high curving boughs and there
were two indians in it
i lingered with some excitement to see
if it would appear again around the
other side of the island
and in less than five minutes it came
into view
there were less than 200 yards between
us and the indians
sitting on their haunches were paddling
swiftly in my direction
i never paddled faster in my life than i
did in those next few minutes
when i turned to look again the indians
had altered their course
and were again circling the island the
sun was sinking behind the forests on
the mainland
and the crimson colored clouds of sunset
were reflected in the waters of the lake
when i looked round for the last time
and saw the big bark canoe and its two
dusky occupants still going round the
island
then the shadows deepened rapidly the
lake grew black
and the night wind blew its first breath
in my face as i turned a corner
and a projecting bluff of rock hid from
my view both island and canoe
the utter loneliness of our moose camp
on skeleton lake
had impressed us from the beginning in
the quebec backwoods
five days by trail and canoe from
civilization and perhaps the singular
name
contributed a little to the sensation of
eeriness that made itself felt in the
camp circle
when once the sun was down and the late
october mists began rising from the lake
and winding their way in among the tree
trunks
for in these regions all names of lakes
and hills and islands
have their origin in some actual event
taking either the name of a chief
participant
such as smith's ridge or claiming a
place in the map
by perpetuating some special feature of
the journey or the scenery
such as long island deep rapids or rainy
lake
all names thus have their meaning and
are usually pretty recently acquired
while the majority are self-explanatory
and suggest human and pioneer relations
skeleton lake therefore was a name full
of suggestion
and though none of us knew the origin or
the story of its birth
we were all conscious of a certain
luxurious atmosphere that haunted its
shores and islands
and but for the evidences of recent
moose tracks in its neighborhood
we should probably have pitched our
tents elsewhere
for several hundred miles in any
direction we knew of only one other
party of whites
they had journeyed up on the train with
us getting in at north bay
and hailing from boston way a common
goal and object
had served by way of introduction but
the acquaintance had made little
progress
this noisy aggressive yankee did not
suit our fancy much as a possible
neighbor
and it was only a slight intimacy
between his chief guide jake the swede
and one of our men that kept the thing
going at all
they went into camp on beaver creek 50
miles and more to the west of us
but that was six weeks ago and seemed as
many months
for days and nights passed slowly in
these solitudes and the scale of time
changes wonderfully our men always
seemed to know by instinct pretty well
where the other fellows were moving
but in the interval no one had come
across their trails or once so much as
heard their rifle shots
our little camp consisted of the
professor his wife a splendid shot and
keen woods woman
and myself we had a guide a piece and
hunted daily in pairs from before
sunrise till dark
it was our last evening in the woods and
the professor was lying in my little
wedge tent
discussing the dangers of hunting alone
in couples this way
the flap of the tent hung back and let
in fragrant odors of cooking over an
open wood fire
everywhere there was bustle and
preparation and one canoe already lay
packed with moose horns
her nose pointing southwards if an
accident happened to one of them he was
saying
the survivor's story when he returned to
camp would be entirely unsupported
evidence wouldn't it
because you see and he went on laying
down the law after the manner of
professors
until i became so bored that my
attention began to wander to pictures
and memories of the scenes we were just
about to leave
garden lake with its hundred islands the
rapids out of round pond
the countless vistas of forest crimson
and gold in the autumn sunshine
and the starlet knights we had spent
watching in cold cramped positions for
the wary moose
on lonely lakes among the hills the hum
of the professor's voice in time grew
more
soothing a nod or a grunt was all the
reply he looked for
fortunately he loathed interruptions i
think i could almost have gone to sleep
under his very nose
perhaps i did sleep for a brief interval
then it all came about so quickly and
the tragedy of it was so
unexpected and painful throwing our
peaceful camp into momentary confusion
that now it all seems to have happened
with the uncanny swiftness of a dream
first there was the abrupt ceasing of
the droning voice and then the running
of quick little steps over the pine
needles
and the confusion of men's voices in the
next instant the professor's wife was at
the tent door
hatless her face white her hunting
bloomers bagging at the wrong places
a rifle in her hand and her words
running into one another anyhow
quick harry it's rushed in i was asleep
and it woke me
something's happened you must deal with
it in a second we were outside the tent
with our rifles
my god i heard the professor exclaim as
if he had first made the discovery
it is rushton i saw the guides helping
dragging a man out of a canoe a brief
space of deep silence followed in which
i heard only the waves from the canoe
washing up on the sand
and then immediately after came the
voice of a man talking with amazing
rapidity
and with odd gaps between his words it
was rushton telling his story
and the tones of his voice now
whispering now almost shouting
mixed with sobs and solemn oaths and
frequent appeals to the deity
somehow or others struck the false note
at the very start
and before any of us guessed or knew
anything at all
something moved secretly between his
words a shadow veiling the stars
destroying the peace of our little camp
and touching us all personally with an
indefinable sense of horror and distrust
i can see that group to this day with
all the detail of a good photograph
standing halfway between the fire light
and the darkness a slight mist rising
from the lake
the frosty stars and our men in silence
that was all sympathy
dragging rushton across the rocks
towards the campfire their moccasins
crunched on the sand and slipped several
times on the stones beneath the weight
of the limp exhausted body
and i can still see every inch of the
paired cedar branch he had used for a
paddle
on that lonely and dreadful journey but
what struck me most as it struck us all
was the limp exhaustion of his body
compared to the strength of his
utterance and the tearing rush of his
words
a vigorous driving power was there at
work forcing out the tail
red hot and throbbing full of
discrepancies and the strangest
contradictions
and the nature of this driving power i
first began to appreciate when they had
lifted him into the circle of firelight
and i saw his face grey under the tan
terror in his eyes
tears too hair and beard awry and listen
to the wild stream of words pouring
forth without ceasing
i think we all understood then but it
was only after many years that anyone
dared to confess what he thought
there was matt morris my guide silver
fizz
whose real name was unknown and who bore
the title of his favorite drink
and huge hank milligan all ears and kind
intention
and there was rushton pouring out his
ready-made tail with ever-shifting eyes
turning from face to face seeking
confirmation of details none had
witnessed but himself
and one other silver fizz was the first
to recover from the shock of the thing
and to realize with a natural sense of
chivalry common to most genuine
backwoodsmen
that the man was at a terrible
disadvantage at any rate he was the
first to start putting the matter to
rights
never mind telling it just now he said
in a gruff voice but with real
gentleness
get a bite to eat first and then let her
go afterwards
better have a horn of whiskey too it
ain't all packed yet i guess
i couldn't eat or drink a thing cried
the other good lord don't you see man i
want to talk to someone first
i want to get it out of me to someone
who can answer i've had nothing but
trees to talk with for three days
and i can't carry it alone any longer
those cursed silent trees
i've told it to them a thousand times
now just see here it was this way
when we started out from camp he looked
fearfully about him
and we realized it was useless to stop
him the story was bound to come
and come it did now the story itself was
nothing out of the way
such tales are told by the dozen around
any campfire where
men who have knocked about in the woods
are in the circle it was the way he told
it that made our flesh creep
he was near the truth all along but he
was skimming it
and the skimming took off the cream that
might have saved his soul
of course he smothered it in words odd
words too
melodramatic poetic out of the way words
that lie
just on the edge of frenzy of course too
he kept asking us each in turn
scanning our faces with those restless
frightened eyes of his
what would you have done what else could
i do and was that my fault
but that was nothing for he was no milk
and water fellow who dealt in hints and
suggestions
he told his story boldly forcing his
conclusions upon us
as if we had been so many wax cylinders
of a phonograph that would repeat
accurately what had been told to us
and these questions i have mentioned he
used to emphasize any special point that
he seemed to think required such
emphasis
the fact was however the picture of what
had actually happened was so vivid still
in his own mind that it reached ours by
a process of telepathy which he could
not control or prevent
all through his true false words this
picture stood forth in fearful detail
against the shadows behind him
he could not veil much less obliterate
it we knew
and i always thought he knew that we
knew
the story itself as i have said was
sufficiently ordinary
jake and himself in a nine-foot canoe
had upset in the middle of a lake
and had held hands across the upturned
craft for several hours
eventually cutting holes in her ribs to
stick their arms through and grasp hands
lest the numbness of the cold water
should overcome them
they were miles from shore and the wind
was drifting them down upon a little
island
but when they got within a few hundred
yards of the island they realized to
their horror that they would after all
drift past it
it was then that the quarrel began jake
was for leaving the canoe and swimming
rushton believed in waiting till they
actually had passed the island and were
sheltered from the wind
then they could make the island easily
by swimming canoe and all
but jake refused to give in and after a
short struggle
rushton admitted that there was a
struggle got free from the canoe
and disappeared without a single cry
rushton held on and proved the
correctness of his theory
and finally made the island canoe and
all after being in the water over five
hours
he described to us how he crawled up
onto the shore and fainted at once
with his feet lying half in the water
how lost and terrified he felt upon
regaining consciousness in the dark
how the canoe had drifted away and his
extraordinary luck in finding it caught
again at the end of the island by a
projecting cedar branch
he told us that the little axe another
bit of real luck
had caught in the thwart when the canoe
turned over and how the little bottle in
his pocket holding the emergency matches
was whole and dry
he made a blazing fire and searched the
island from end to end
calling upon jake in the darkness but
getting no answer
till finally so many half-drowned men
seemed to come crawling out of the water
onto the rocks
and vanish among the shadows when he
came up with them that he lost his nerve
completely and returned to lie down by
the fire till the daylight came
he then cut a bow to replace the lost
paddles and after one more useless
search for his lost companion he got
into the canoe
fearing every moment he would upset
again and crossed over to the mainland
he knew roughly the position of our
camping place and after paddling day and
night and making many weary portages
without food or covering
he reached us two days later this more
or less was the story
and we knowing where of he spoke knew
that every word was literally true
and at the same time went to the
building up of a hideous and prodigious
lie
once the recital was over he collapsed
and silver fizz
after a general expression of sympathy
from the rest of us
came again to the rescue but now mister
you just gotta eat and drink whether
you've a mine too or no
and matt morris cooked that night soon
had the fried trout and bacon
and the wheat cakes and hot coffee
passing around a rather silent and
oppressed circle
so we ate round the fire ravenously as
we had eaten every night for the past
six weeks
but with this difference that there was
one among us who was more than ravenous
and he gorged in spite of all our
devices he somehow kept himself the
center of observation
when his tin mug was empty morris
instantly passed the tea pail
when he began to mop up the bacon grease
with the dough on his fork
hank reached out for the frying pan and
the can of steaming boiled potatoes was
always by his side
and there was another difference as well
he was sick
terribly sick before the meal was over
and this sudden nausea after food was
more eloquent than words of what the man
had passed through on his dreadful
foodless ghost-haunted journey of 40
miles to our camp
in the darkness he thought he would go
crazy he said
there were voices in the trees and
figures were always lifting themselves
out of the water
or from behind boulders to look at him
and make awful signs
jake constantly peered at him through
the underbrush and everywhere the
shadows were moving
with eyes footsteps and following shapes
we tried hard to talk of other things
but it was no use
for he was bursting with a rehearsal of
his story and refused to allow himself
the chances we were so willing and
anxious to grant him
after a good night's rest he might have
had more self-control and better
judgment
and would probably have acted
differently but as it was we found it
impossible to help him once the pipes
were lit
and the dishes cleared away it was
useless to pretend any longer
the sparks from the burning logs
zigzagged upwards into a sky brilliant
with stars
it was all wonderfully still and
peaceful and the forest odors floated to
us on the sharp autumn air
the cedar fire smelt sweet and we could
just hear the gentle wash of tiny waves
along the shore
all was calm beautiful and remote from
the world of men
and passion it was indeed a night to
touch the soul
and yet i think none of us heeded these
things
a bull moose might almost have thrust
his great head over our shoulders
and escaped unnoticed the death of jake
the swede with its sinister setting
was the real presence that held the
center of the stage and compelled
attention
you won't perhaps care to come along
mister said morris by way of a beginning
but i guess i'll go with one of the boys
here and have a hunt for it
sure said hank jake and i done some
biggest trips together in the old days
and i'll do that much for him
it's deep water they tell me around them
islands added silver fizz
but we'll find it sure enough if it's
there
they all spoke of the body as it
there was a minute or two of heavy
silence and then rushed and again burst
out with his story
and almost the identical words he had
used before
it was almost as if he had learned it by
heart he wholly failed to appreciate the
efforts of the others to let him off
silver fizz rushed in hoping to stop him
morris and hank closely following his
lead
i once knew another traveling partner of
his he began quickly
used to live down moosejaw rapid's way
is that so
said hank kinda useful sort of fellow
chimed in morris
all the idea the men had was to stop the
tongue wagging before the discrepancies
became so glaring that we should be
forced to take notice of them
and ask questions but just as well try
to stop an angry bull moose on the run
or prevent beaver creek freezing in
midwinter by throwing in pebbles near
the shore
out it came and though the discrepancy
this time was
insignificant it somehow brought us all
in a second
face to face with the inevitable and
dreaded climax
and so i tramped all over that little
bit of an island hoping he might somehow
have gotten in without my knowing it
and always thinking i heard that awful
last cry of his in the darkness
and then the night dropped down
impenetrably like a damn thick blanket
out of the sky
and all eyes fell away from his face
hank poked up the logs with his boot and
morris seized an ember in his bare
fingers to light his pipe
although it was already emitting clouds
of smoke but the professor caught the
ball flying
i thought you said he sank without a cry
he remarked quietly
looking straight up into the frightened
face opposite and then riddling
mercilessly the confused explanation
that followed
the cumulative effect of all these
forces hitherto
so rigorously repressed now made itself
felt
and the circle spontaneously broke up
everybody moving at once by a common
instinct
the professor's wife left the party
abruptly with excuses about an early
start next morning
she first shook hands with rushton
mumbling something about his comfort in
the night
the question of his comfort however
devolved by force of circumstances upon
myself
and he shared my tent just before
wrapping up in my double blankets
for the night was bitterly cold he
turned and began to
explain that he had a habit of talking
in his sleep and hoped i would wake him
if he disturbed me by doing so
well he did talk in his sleep and it
disturbed me very much indeed
the anger and violence of his words
remain with me to this day
and it was clear in a minute that he was
living over again some portion of the
scene upon the lake
i listened horror struck for a moment or
two and then understood that i was face
to face with one of two alternatives
i must continue an unwilling
eavesdropper or i must waken him
the former was impossible for me yet i
shrank from the latter with the greatest
repugnance
and in my dilemma i saw the only way out
of the difficulty and at once accepted
it
cold though it was i crawled stealthily
out of my warm sleeping bag and left the
tent
intending to keep the old fire a light
under the stars and spend the remaining
hours till daylight in the open
as soon as i was out i noticed at once
another figure moving silently along the
shore
it was hank milligan and it was plain
enough what he was doing
he was examining the holes that had been
cut in the upper ribs of the canoe
he looked half ashamed when i came up to
him and mumbled something about
not being able to sleep for the cold but
there
standing together beside the overturned
canoe we both saw that the holes were
far too small for a man's hand and arm
and could not possibly have been cut by
two men hanging on for their lives in
deep water
those holes had been made afterwards
hank said nothing to me and i said
nothing to hank and presently he moved
off to collect logs for the fire which
needed replenishing
for it was a piercingly cold night and
there were many degrees of frost
three days later hank and silver fizz
followed with stumbling footsteps the
old indian trail
that leads from beaver creek to the
southwards
a hammock was slung between them and it
weighed heavily
yet neither of the men complained and
indeed speech between them was almost
nothing
their thoughts however were exceedingly
busy and the terrible secret of the
woods which formed their burden
weighed far more heavily than the
uncouth shifting mass
that lay in the swinging hammock and
tugged so severely at their shoulders
they had found it in four feet of water
not more than a couple of yards from the
lee shore of the island
and in the back of the head was a long
terrible wound
which no man could possibly have
inflicted upon himself
you